et
avec nous on a besoin des lumières de
gérard araud diplomate ex ambassadeur de
france à washington au conseil de
sécurité csars bonsoir bonsoir alors
monsieur poutine on le rappelle c'est le
noeud du problème veut une garantie
entre une forme de garantie que
l'ukraine ne soit jamais accepté au sein
de l'otan on va voir une carte tout à
l'heure les lipides bleus qui ont
entouré de plus en plus fortement la
russie est ce que vous voyez encore ce
soir
l'option diplomatique comme et à une
voie réaliste l'apport que monsieur
poutine trouvent une voie de sortie que
les européens il américains aussi
vous savez je crois que c'est allé un
peu vite que de penser que donner la
gare de cette garantie que réclamera
monsieur poutine mettrait fin au conflit
parce que monsieur poutine c'est très
bien comme l'a dit le chancelier
allemand comme l'a dit la journaliste
que nous venons d'entendre que l'entrée
de l'ukraine dans l'otan n'est
absolument pas dans notre
considérer pour les dix ou quinze années
qui viennent et donc on ne voit pas
pourquoi il était nécessaire de faire
cette crise extrêmement menaçant cent
trente mille hommes et donc c'est la
première question qui donc il faut se
poser que veut vraiment monsieur poutine
parce que de nouveaux on ne fait pas la
guerre pour une éventualité qui pourrait
arriver dans les 15 prochaines années
n'oubliez pas la lettre l'article qu'a
écrit monsieur poutine en juillet sur
l'ukraine où il disait à la fin nous
sommes un même peuple donc on peut
craindre que l'objectif réel de la
russie ce soir d'un excellent ukraine à
sa sphère d'influencé dont cmea rose que
vous dites c'est que monsieur poutine ne
cherche pas une porte de sortie mais il
cherche un prétexte pour entrer en
ukraine alors justement non c'est une
question que jamais il y à votre
question il n'ya que monsieur poutine
qui peut y répondre
c'était une caractéristique du système
russe qui est totalement verticale même
lavrov le ministre des affaires
étrangères ne sais pas ce que veut
vraiment ce que veut vraiment poutine
ont tout cas je car maintenant on l'a vu
avec les cinq heures d'entretien de
d'emmanuel macron ont peut-être renverra
avec le chancelier allemand mais on n'a
pas vraiment l'impression aux que
poutine veut une négociation
vous savez pendant les cinq heures
d'entretien avec emmanuel macron ça a
été des heures et des heures où poutine
a répété à ressasser tous ces sentiments
de frustration tout les malheurs de la
russie au cours des 20 ou 30 de trente
dernières années donc qu'il est il est
difficile vraiment de savoir jusqu'où il
veut aller quelles sont vraiment les
concessions qu'ils demandent et et de
l'autre côté c'est quand même assez rare
de voir les conférences de presse à
washington celle de vendredi dernier
hier on disait c'est i mean à ces mêmes
mercredi que moscou va attaquer les
amériques montlaur on a changé un peu le
discours aujourd'hui mais quand même on
a l'impression que washington et quand
être étaient convaincus qu'une attaque
arrivait et le disait comme ça
ouvertement quand même incroyable non un
mois je dois avouer que je ne comprends
pas je n'ai jamais vu en 40 ans les
etats unis se mettre dans une position
de commentateurs ils commentent
l'actualité en annonçant eh bien ils
vont attaquer mercredi aux avions
attaqué vendredi ou alors je peux vous
dire qu'ils peuvent attaquer c'est quand
même extrêmement curieux ce n'est pas
une politique je ne vois pas vraiment
quel est l'objectif des états unis par
ce genre de déclarations peut-être
ont-ils un syndrome de kaboul donc ils
ne veulent pas être surpris par un
désastre comme ça si il attaque si les
russes attaque ils pourront dire on vous
l'avait dit si les russes n'attaque pas
ils pourront dire mais c'est à cause
c'est grâce à nous qui n'ont pas attaqué
je dois avouer que comme vous je trouve
toutes ces déclarations parce qu'il y en
a eu un avec ce livre mbaye dème
extrêmement étrange mais charron là on
le sait les américains ne vont pas dire
à monsieur poutine
c'est hors de question qu'un jour dans
1001 l'ukraine fasse partie de l'otan
l'ukraine est un pays souverain et aura
le droit de choisir ici elle le vrai
pour aller rejoindre le tan tan boon ne
recevra pas totalement ce qu'il veut
alors si tenté que c'est son prétexte
est ce que vous attendez
malheureusement sk une invasion quelques
elle est là les probabilités dans votre
esprit qu'on se retrouve avec une guerre
alors d'abord d'abord plusieurs choses
il est tout à fait possible de dire que
l'ukraine entrera pas dans l'otan sans
porter atteinte à un principe vous avez
vous dit vous donner c'est un bon
diplomate première partie le lot l'otan
est ouvert à tous les pays deuxième
partie l'otan est ouvert aux pays qui
satisfont aux critères abc or comme par
hasard ukraine ne satisfera pas aux
critères abc donc on peut donner des
garanties c'est vraiment on veut donner
des garanties ça c'est la première chose
on n'a pas besoin de vraiment de
dalé tout au goût de ce que demande la
russie pour lui fournir des candidats
mais toi là
je pense que je pense que la vraie
question qu'on se pose tous c'est est-ce
que ça suffira parce que le vin poutine
a quand même été est extrêmement vague
dans ses demandes et elles sont
extrêmement jeu général il a beaucoup il
se plaque de plâtre aux 1 il se plaint
au fond de la sécurité européenne
deuxième sujet pour répondre à votre
question vous savez que attaqué le
l'ukraine ça peut se faire de deux
manières différentes
ça peut être simplement une attaque
informatique
ça peut être des frappes aériennes ça va
être l'occupation de marioupol c'est à
dire de fermer d'ukraine de la mer
d'azov donc il ya toute une hier il ya
vraiment tout une
radio fonctionne tout à l'ensemble des
options qui s'offrent à est donc entre
la carte au talent et des incidents on a
encore lui il a encore le choix bon
alors on va se reparler gérard araud
merci beaucoup de lumière
comme vous êtes le seul qui a la réponse
à ces questions ce soit c'est monsieur
poutine lui-même
exactement au revoir à bientôt ouah
bientôt pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit